es un clima un poquito tenso como
ustedes lo han dicho ya son muchos
asuntos que se acumulan y que hace que
los franceses no están viviendo de
manera serena tuvimos un montón de
asuntos que tienen que ver con el islam
y hay una cierta tensión en la sociedad
francesa acerca de este tema el 29 de
octubre es una fecha importante para el
islam es el aniversario de la fecha del
nacimiento del profeta mahomed no
sabemos si eso tiene importancia así
porque hoy entonces sucedieron estos
hechos un caso es que efectivamente y
francia- y manuel marco ya empezaron una
nueva etapa en su política tanto
interior como exterior en el cual el
islam va a tener una posición central
todos la que toda la clase política
empezó a reaccionar hoy a decir
necesitamos mucho más que nuestras leyes
necesitamos darle más duro al islamismo
necesitamos que nuestra presidente
responda a lo que está pasando
y al cual el presidente está intentando
responder con tranquilidad y la
necesidad de estar unidos todos contra
la lucha contra el terrorismo y de por
favor no hacer el amalgama entre islam e
islamismo entre los musulmanes franceses
y los terroristas que en su gran mayoría
no son franceses entonces si bien de
pronto no hay una conexión evidente
entre todos estos hechos si hay un
ambiente que es propicio a las tensiones
y unos actos así bárbaros pero de unas
personas que no están conectados
necesariamente entre sí pero que son
unos radicalizados y que deciden de su
manera personal y improvisada cometer un
acto terrorista para hacer pasar un
mensaje porque estos atentados fueron
perpetrados en contra de símbolos un
profesor que enseñaba la laicidad y la
libertad de pensamiento ahora una
iglesia católica entonces podemos pensar
que son símbolos es una guerra de
símbolos que es propio del terrorismo es
de hacer
tierra de manera económica para generar
un montón de un máximo de trauma en la
sociedad y una atención mediática
importante